ねぇいいねぇ
こんにちははじめ社長です今日は塾奴が多かった
軍法で紹介なんですけど
率直に言いましょうあたらセンサー便が
出ないんです
大抵姉コーナーだら新学期とかそういう時期にシャーペンがてるんですやっぱり氏は
卒業と加入独特校にどうするからさ
心機一転してそれに合わせて分蜂群お顔を見たいなとちょっと多いから僕が多分
春先とかが一番新しいシャーペンとが出るんじゃねーかと思ってたんですけども
なんと本当です今年はほぼゼロでしたほぼゼロです本当に
新しいシリーズがさあ点が出なかったですことしは出たとしてもなんかあれでドクター
グリップのグリップが3色ここで服たグリップのこの部分が中3速でそのカラー
ボーダーで遊べるタイプとかとちょっとマイナーチェンジぐらいしか出なくて非常にね
そう開始するまでもなかったら今年はちょっとこう目新しい商品がなかったなっていう
の
シャーペン状態の月曜でございます今はねぇくるとかの波が来いって
シャー芯が折れない時代なんですよ僕の消化したをレンズとか
ベルガードとかポレンとか今は食べてしゃー勉強会はちょっと写真を折れないシャー
ペンが今最強な状態になってますよそのシャー芯が折れにくいシャーペンね刺しゴール
にくいシャーペンの時代に今途中
にしててそれを超す新たなギミックがないとこの先には進めないという状態なんですよ
たぶんね俺べくそんな専門家じゃないといって言うことが正しいと思わないんですけど
も現時点ではとりあえず後レンズをレイドでるけどこれさぁ芯の折れないシャーペン
なぁ今
一応トップに躍り出ているわけです結局ね写真撮れなかったらいい子ねをレンズとかも
しんが0.2だから細いから来るとが入ったに回転する必要もないっていう結構いいの
で高は状態に陥っています
シャーペン業界は静雄
いいねサーペンをつくっている方々も苦労してると思いますよ
この先へどうやってもれなくて細いシャーペンのギミックを超えるかっていうこの先
新しいシャーペンが出たらもうすごいと思ってます国はっていう実はね
例えばサーフィン業界ので結構最強状態までたどり着いているんですよもう極限で結局
現場ですよ別に
俺が言ってることが全部正しいいって
いうわけじゃないからあくまでも始めワールドに入ってるのではじめシャーペイバー
ワールド第年のお話なのでこれは世界的に映るとどうかは分かりませんという話で
ございますず僕は講談社便についての話は他のその分郷家だするキーワードにとって
それが正しいか正しくないかと言うのは僕が判断することではございませんそして僕が
間違った情報つあるかも知れませんこれについては誤解成績に多くとができませんで
そこはご了承よろしくお願い致しますという感じでちょっと北に
独断と偏見だ今僕の中でスマッシュですね最強じゃん
アーチャーペンの会社の皆さん新しいのを待ちしております
par
me